[Music]
nasa is counting down to a christmas
morning launch of the new james webb
space telescope two days and counting at
10 billion it will be the biggest and
most expensive science instrument ever
sent into space
and it could help answer some of your
most pressing questions about the
universe i know you've got some but as
mark straussman shows us hundreds of
things have to go right before the
telescope can capture a single image
from its perch a million miles beyond
earth the james webb space telescope
will glimpse the dawn of time like
nothing before it the universe is this
13.8 billion year story and we're
missing some key paragraphs in the very
first chapter
nasa astrophysicist amber strong hopes
webb's discoveries will fill in the
blanks you're talking about potentially
answering some of the questions that
have occurred to people since the first
people looked up at the stars absolutely
we don't know how galaxies got their
start we will hopefully be able to see
those first galaxies for the very first
time and of course galaxies are the
homes of stars and stars are the homes
of planets and planets of course are the
homes of life and so this telescope is
definitely going to be our next giant
leap in our search for habitable planets
in our galaxy webb's 18 gold-plated
hexagonal shaped mirrors will align to
create one giant mirror it's 21 feet
across six times larger than the one on
the hubble space telescope for more than
three decades hubble has given us
stunning humbling views of the universe
but webb will be a major upgrade like a
night vision camera this infrared
telescope will search for heat
signatures of the very first light after
the big bang mike menzel is the web's
mission systems engineer we're looking
for some of the faintest objects that
there are to see in the universe in fact
we are looking for the faintest objects
if the telescope doesn't get cold then
it will actually glow brighter than the
objects we're looking for to block the
sun's heat from blinding web engineers
designed a first of its kind sun shield
the size of a tennis court its five
layers will keep the telescope side more
than 600 degrees colder than the sun
facing side this is material this is
captain material that makes up those
layers of the sun shield this material
here is about two thousandth of an inch
thick yeah it's amazing how much how
much responsibility is something this
thin has yes it is yes
and because that sun shield is so big it
and everything else had to fold up to
fit inside the rocket once in space webb
will carefully unfold and rebuild itself
like robotic origami it'll be two and a
half weeks of high anxiety
project manager bill oaks it's more
complex than any satellite nasa has ever
launched it is hands down the
complexities of its deployment the
materials that it's been made of has
never been tried by a nasa mission
before if any one of 344 parts fail the
entire mission could be jeopardized
about one-third involved deploying that
sun shield 1300 feet of cables almost
600 pulley assemblies and it all has to
work the essential doesn't have to be a
hundred percent perfect but it's got to
be pretty damn close to being 100
perfect for it to work a million miles
out something goes wrong there's no call
in triple a now that is no call in
triple a but i am confident that we did
everything we could on the ground to
maximize the probability of success of
this mission webb's first image is about
six months away worth the wait for the
chance to see baby pictures of the
universe for cbs mornings mark strassman
greenbelt maryland nice
it's a 10 billion dollar project pretty
big gamble they're putting it on a
rocket i hope it works i'm definitely
rooting for it thanks mark